[Music]
hello they reject nation man I can't
come in tube it's a table no more
serious channel the history of GI Jo a
Real American Hero 1982 edition this is
from a channel called Michael mercy
forgive us for reacting to your video
because we're gonna crap all over now
that's not that guy this is top of war
tier video requester man named Jason
Dolan and here's what he said to me I
thought this would be a fun video to
watch I recently discovered this channel
and I think your fan base or a portion
of it meaning 1000 viewers will love
watching all these videos this is the
first one I watched similar to the
Netflix series the toys that made us
they also shout out my friend larry Hama
who is a total adjourned yeah so I'd
love to send this reaction video to him
well Larry I hope you're satisfied with
what we have to offer today yeah Larry
he'd get a kick out of it Larry sounds
like a great guy Larry egg for you
basically created GI Joe oh wow that's a
bold statement good thing Jon and I are
huge GI geo fans grew up on the cartoon
played with all the toys they're not
toys Greg they're action figures Jesus I
am sorry
family friend I was lucky enough to
write a you know I'm gonna tell you the
rest of this message
[Music]
yo Jose welcome to the very first
patreon polls video ooh I finally
discovered how to make polls on the
patreon page you expect us to believe
that it did take us like a year to
figure that and his first topic was a
burn burn that's all we put the first
vote ended in a three-way tie but in the
sudden-death repol GI Joe was there
awesome so grateful to all the good
brothers and sisters on patreon for
their support and these polls are
another awesome way to let these amazing
folks have some influence on what videos
I do I know GI Joe existed before the
80s as the 12-inch army doll or an
action figure as it's properly known to
me GI Joe will always be a real American
Hero
damn straight this particular
incarnation of Joe lasted from 1982 to
1994 and produced an astounding 500
figures Wow and 250 vehicles including
the largest playset ever built the line
lasted so long it was supported by
factual check for an animated series by
two Studios one of them amazing
and the other was deke today's history
lesson typically looks at the relaunch
of GI Joe in 1982
[Music]
okay I feel the need to do this quick
public service announcement for the
nitpickers or I'll be seeing for years
to come
hey don't make fun of marginal 82
straight arm joe's cabinet for the 83
swivel arm battle grip free releases so
rather than digitally distorting the
elbows for the whole video for the few
people who like to ignore entire videos
filled with all sorts of information and
fun stuff and just nitpick the one thing
that wasn't perfect let's all just
pretend these are the straight arm
versions I thinking it's what we used to
do all the time back in the 80s 40 men
scaled the figures from 12 inch to 3 and
3/4 inches because of the success of
Kenner's Star Wars line the idea for the
relaunch came about according to Mark
Tom editor-in-chief at the time Jim
shooters from a bathroom powwow between
the presidents of Hasbro and Marvel
Comics Marvel didn't just produce the GI
Joe comic as a commercial for the toys
they breathed life into the toy line
this is why GI Joe in the 80s had that
same fun and fantastical yet slightly
grounded in the real world feel as all
the other Marvel comics
most people look at GI Joe as part of
the Hasbro universe but my GI Joe is
more part of the Marvel Universe Larry
Hammond I feel like I should inspire
episode just on Larry's contribution so
are you more like 100 episodes that's
Larry Larry is and always will be the
father of GI Joe to me Larry Anam he was
developing a comic book called fury
force about an elite special missions
force led by Nick Fury son when
everybody else passed on the project
Larry adapted his fury force concept and
brought life to all the characters it
was a perfect fit for him who had served
in the military and knew all about the
genuine lingo and procedures but it also
worked in Hollywood and knew how to add
some sizzle to the steak as well
appearing as an actor
mash and Saturday Night Live a much
better resolution Larry well the
previous active experience was playing a
pumpkin in the school Thanksgiving show
Goodwin created Cobra Commander
the Joe's arch-nemesis and everything
else was larry Hama in terms of
character development these were just
grunts sorry
each larger-than-life figure was also
grounded in reality with a file named
earth place specialties and BIOS Emma's
quirky sense of humor ensured that this
wouldn't be a grim toy line about the
dogs of war
his sense of humor made being all they
could be more than a job it was an
adventure
he showed that war wasn't just hell it
could be fun okay but serious yeah
that's a message in a new light Larry
have just had dreams of being a serious
military person it's GI Joe made them
seem like real-life superheroes men and
women to be admired symbols of honor
chattering virtue when does the news
Marla Wynne and charisma comes up with
straightforward Jonathan Lee huh
terrorism unit created to fight the
forces of Cobra organization to
determine
Hasbro spared no expense on the toy line
featuring beautiful action packed almost
photorealistic card art on every
individual figure and vehicle box do
remember the Sousa eight vehicles
released four of which included figures
eleven single carded figures carrying
case and a male in figure I still
remember seeing these toys for the first
time in the toy section at highway
market in Kitchener in 1980 M / Jun and
I hadn't read the comic yet I had no
idea yeah it was but I immediately knew
it was special the true grit on each
Joe's face the exploding background and
the figures themselves this bounding for
1982 and maybe still even by today's
standards and I want to see toys like
that oh very stuck these are better than
an electric train set but knees and
elbows that bent swiveling waist
shoulder and hip sockets that allowed
for so much more range than Star Wars
figures did yes and real looking guns
not laser guns tiny intricate parts like
visors for that I don't like how this
promotes violence Childress's YT kids
grow up made out of hard like his grown
he seemed more like miniature poseable
models than children's toys fearing the
bad guys wouldn't sell almost all of the
vehicles were from the Joe motor pool
the three extra vehicles where the RAM
cycle with side Gatling yeah
especially G with driver clutch and the
motorized boat bat tank with stealer
given like an old one right forwards and
backwards that's dangerous
technically vehicles but that's the term
that's generally used for items that
came in boxes the MMS that was after was
an old bat or fam and included the JD's
original commander Kurn gave a toilet
that batteries and how laser also
towable included Grand Slam yeah what
cannon was a stain cake tag June's
breakfast he had on the show in order to
give fighting chance
commercials featured the snail stealing
Joe vehicles you buy insult national
headquarters would be able to stores
expensive that's just your imagination
taking a quarter soldier Cobra officer
and Cobra Commander of the 11 standard
carded figures released nine of them
were Joe's there was the communications
officer and my first Joe breaker this is
wait come here the laser trooper flash
damnit flash brothers first Joe
infantryman grunt coming into old buddy
heavy machine gunner rock and roll short
fuse right the Ranger stalker you ass
and azúcar soldiers zap nothing better
than a good kabooms to open a closed
doors the mysterious silent commando
Snake Eyes now when it's played by Henry
gold a marble no thanks there weren't
any females on the guy from prison a
strong female characters in the military
in comics or animation up to that point
Marvel told Hasbro and we've got to make
one here read that Minea Wonder Woman
and Shira mentioned all the time in
terms of strong female comic and
animation heroines of the eighties first
what is this concept wrong you know
women oh yeah get out in my nineteen
eighties now I know the really strong
tween gorilla gropes turns that the bad
guys wouldn't sell so releasing army
builders was a way of giving fans an
incentive to not just by one but
multiples
and fake-face was released in 1982 as
the first male in figure requiring five
flag points and a whopping 50 cents for
postage and handling yes many kids
experience the absolute joy and
excitement of receiving a toy in the
mail for the first time thanks to GI Joe
in 1982 now we have MS in crime and have
been reliving that excitement through
eBay Amazon and other online stores
ever since well some of them some don't
have as much patience as they had its
kids the first issue of the GI Joe comic
was released in June of 82 nee kettle it
was written with a Larry hammer it's got
the same fun glib vibe of the Sun both
show that would come out the following
year but the stakes are a bit higher
not everyone here shoots out of
exploding aircraft and there is an
actual risk of serious injury or death
after rereading some of these classic
early Joe comics my only question to
Hasbro is why isn't this your GI Joe
movie Larry's done all the work for you
it's here it's great it's cool it's
magic give him the credit he deserves
and use this as the blueprint for your
movies all you need to go to Marvel
magining right be truly a genuine it
showed America Shepherd the Joe desert
timeless it worked then and it'll work
today because the themes hammer used are
timeless
[Music]
and you haven't seen rise of cobra
bumper face the first year had been a
gamble but with the incredible success
of the line the doors were blown off the
hinges for more unique-looking
characters gear and vehicles as well as
added articulation going from the
straight arm to swivel arm battle grip
but that's a story for the 1983 history
video got a joe memory like to share
scroll down and go to town feel free to
share the video with your fellow joes if
you'd like to take part in upcoming
patreon polls head over to the patreon
page listed in the show do it now
and join the force hit subscribe of
course
[Music]
sorry you hear he gets slide guitar
slide guitar it's totally different
finger pattern lame that's yeah they
have contests that where you can win
money for doing that
so I've won can I borrow some money
no so let me get this straight
yeah Marvel suggested doing a female
character before they cast brie Larson
and Captain Marvel oh wow this changes
everything was Marvel always woke oh my
god they always think that women had a
place in in superhero and comic-book you
know lore I thought they were just
feeling pressured by social media
no there was social media back then you
know it just took a lot longer to get
there well then if when Orville
suggested then scarlet is my favorite
Joe ooh I I think that's a good choice
this is a fascinating video it was
pretty fascinating Michael mercy I have
a few thoughts here how did he
edit this has act air you dare you for
making a channel there's so many
episodes GI Joe yes even if it was one
season that's a lot of episodes I know
and then he just knew the right footage
to flash in for a lot of the lines and
that I liked for everything for the hint
to enhance his reference points did he
first script this edit it and then watch
the whole show again so he knew exactly
which lines to pull like make notes or
was he just there at the editing station
going oh I can use this line here oh I
remember this line this episode's get
that lucky like are you that and it's
like Lapine ik with your Joe knowledge
now admittedly John and I did not grow
up on GI Joe what I yeah you're lying
but we did grow up Americans oh that's
true so we blindly love
mm-hmm a Real American Hero no matter
what it's on the box it's on the box
it's a requirement my GI Joe familiarity
is with the movies that have come out
which I've always been under the belief
that those are 100 percent accurate
mm-hmm that's what every fan has told me
yeah is that Channing Tatum is what the
people have been waiting for for so long
you know it's like we had to sit through
all these comics and action figures and
these cards that have all these origin
place isn't history written on them what
we really want yeah as what finally got
here Stephen Sommers man and the Snake
Eyes character who is getting his own
spin-off movie right now
yeah his own solo film and he doesn't
talk perfect it's gonna be a silent
movie perfect digital storytelling I
cannot wait let me tell you why I think
they haven't been able to successfully
crack a GI Joe war movie because exactly
what I just said a war movie you can
kind of get away with a little bit a
more heightened comic American
patriotism that word patriotism yes
what about patriotic yes
what about Roland Emmerich's the Patriot
that's a whole phrase filled with proper
words that is the proper parade patriot
true story also you know being would
seems like you know it's connected with
in the comic world then when you're
doing like the pictures and stuff or
even with the cartoon it's a cartoon I
think when you do real life it's a lot
harder to capture this like more fun
side of war yeah yeah every cool they
pulled it off I just don't know how you
can Plus why I don't think none of them
the movies have they bother to take
place in a war they're all missions or
like spies or something yeah it almost
seems like from the outside if you could
take some kind of Rambo template and
then warp it to fun warp it to like
over-the-top adventure like it might
work I think if you put it in a
different
if you go back in and look at it through
the scope that it would have been when
they were actually you know first coming
out with the toys and stuff and you know
developing the lore feel like that could
potentially work because yeah it's like
the GI Joe I imagine has developed
through a lens that has a different
foundation for war it's like we would
have just come off of like world war ii
and stuff vibe the everything was
different so like the eighties would be
like to be it not right well yeah but
I'm saying like the people would be
writing this stuff probably we're kids
during you know we're coming up during
World War two and having a parents talk
about that like that's the trickle down
whereas you know Viet Nam's like right
now I feel like yeah now it's harder
because our lexicon for war is more
updated and different and it's not the
Great War anymore like it's a long time
passed and Wars got a lot more
complicated and we ate war imagery in
our big blockbuster movies anyway yeah
so yeah I can see why it's tricky now
without going just full-on blockbuster
fun well they're not like a real war
they're in so you know yeah Captain
America kind of had a bit of that camp
in its montage moments in the first
event
but that's World War two you know it's
I'm much more morally easy to process
war but then I'll also say this I am
just bullshitting I have no idea why
they haven't made a reality that is
actually accurate
I think there's rise in like silly
justification like this stuff I'm saying
there's probably some validity to what
I'm actually riffing about I do think it
would be cool to get that version of GI
Joe because I remember like the opening
scene like I didn't grow up on the show
but I remember the opening and that's
what I've always associated with GI Joe
for sure they've never captured that
kind of tone or spirit so I think even
taking it back to the 80s it's that way
you could have a little bit more of a
colorful vibe a more of a comic book
yell to it or if has burrow just sells
the movie rights to marble then we're
good the movies went so futuristic with
it all but like these are militant it's
like looking at the comics and what I
know about the cartoons it always feels
kind of like a superhero team with
military imagery on top of it well it's
like how he put it that it you know it's
hiding in everything but it's a little
bit more grounded what I thought was
really fascinating about this video was
learning what
made the toys in it of itself so special
I never watch the toys I made us because
I've never grown up like with a heavy
investment in toys before to the degree
of like collecting the action figures
like transformers or whatever the most I
I did with toys now as young as I would
use my imagination play pretend with
like the toys the green soldiers yeah
classic army yeah an army man yes I
would like collect a whole bunch of
those and I would play with those is a
little kid but in action figures like
this those were too expensive doctor so
I couldn't quite play with them mommy
and daddy couldn't afford it and now I'm
a freak I don't fit in with the rest of
the kid everybody pointed you're like
haha you can't play with GI Joe so you
don't understand what any of us are
doing no and you can't be called out in
fascist because they hated America
yeah anti Patriot I really was hmm
starring Mel Gibson Mel Gibson the best
Patriot from Australia that's the seal
of a patriot and well yeah I mean that's
the thing that that intrigued me the
most because yeah I've always been
familiar with GI Joe but what got me
about this video especially and and you
know shouts out to larry Hama here
because like yeah those bios and stuff
and taking the time like I remember
definitely a playing you know
imagination with all sorts of toys
growing up and that's the kind of thing
I would have gotten lost in is yeah
reading those things on the back and
kind of informing that into my mind and
then using that to play with and then
going off on my own direction like it is
pretty cool yeah and I mean I miss like
that's the thing I get the most
nostalgic about from something like this
is the simplicity of just imagining with
your toys because like you don't really
get opportunities to do that as much now
I thought in order to grasp the
storyline of the toys you had to like
him rehash the show watch the show and
then I and to know that the storyline
came with the toys yeah that's a pretty
cool thing it's kind of like when you
would pick up a fighting game when I
would play Tekken they didn't really
tell you what the history was of all
these characters so you'd have to like
look into it yeah you can find oh there
is all the sisters then of course it's
time to on with the game then eventually
they could have like actors the
characters actually speaking in
cutscenes and yeah to really add that an
enhancement level of playability with
your actions
years I think that's really neat and
something I totally take for Greta be
even the mobility of what he was talking
about yeah
how the Star Wars toys sucked and the GI
Joe toys had real guns oh yeah yeah real
laser cannons real Gatling tanks shot
see that those commercials though like
III III III don't they asleep within
that commercial but I like things like
that like a real tank that could like
roll and knock stuff over like that's
the kind of thing I would have gotten
nuts for back in the day yeah but I
never actually got maybe they should do
like an Indian in the cup board movie
where they bring the GI Joe toys to life
and they wreak havoc in Studio City
California small soldiers to smaller
soldiers no because these ones are
scaled down so it's like more soldiers
but yeah we could cross them over with
small so exactly small soldiers all
world after the biggest battle with the
smallest soldiers like and then you find
out it's really just Will Ferrell and
this kid playing the holes I am and
working out their rage issues together
you know he's violent warlike the dad's
also got PTSD instead no wow John this
joke got to Rihanna if we're gonna do I
take movie about war here at least we
can't do PTSD or anything I learned
we gotta get last one oh goodness
gracious no this cut that up no no for
once you make the edgy joke and get the
crap yes yes yes yes but even those
things like the articulating arms stuff
is like stuff we take such for granted
now from like one year's time the lion
was brought in 82 and then 83 they have
like all these advanced articulations as
compared to the first line yeah that
would have been in huge at the time now
I just expect that from the toys I buy
well yeah now everything is you know you
can get like a small computer game for
the same price used
again like an actual toy I play with
toys more than I ever did when I was a
kid I have a room and if you bother me
when I'm playing I'm gonna chase after
you like Pennywise hey the rest of
Jason's message says I was lucky enough
to write a GI Joe screenplay that I
submitted to Marvel and they forwarded
it to Larry inviting me to his home and
we became friends
in the early 2000s ever since then they
have adopted a child together they live
on the waters of Malibu right in the
ocean not even on the sand
nope just on a small dinghy it's
dangerous and the kid has never left he
has become one with the fishes of the
sea speaks their language now worships
this the god Cthulhu the Elder Gods all
of them I hope you enjoy this action
figure deep dive and it's not too
painful to watch now my head hurts I had
a lovely day hope you guys are well I'll
be in LA October 5th
for about a month oh he managed to
escape the dangerous waters he's
spending a month in October fifth people
don't know we're actually like really
mad outside of YouTube we've gone on
dates we've held hands ours our goods
are a really great friend who happens to
be at our work and by extension now
larry Hama is our friend slash slash
suruc writing part father a surrogate
guys you should subscribe to Michael
mercy get her seat if you pledge to his
patreon page you find it isn't for you
and you want a refund from him he will
show you oh mercy mercy
damn it stupid stupid subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell find John on that John Humphrey
Humphrey and he's the great Galba Jason
your shout-out was me reading your
message